the inspiration pretty damn filling down
three words you're gonna die which other
hip-hop artists or true entrepreneur
like in this in this digital era uh I
think the guy to pay attention to is a
guy by the name of CEO Charlie my name
is Charlie jab Lee and Gary has been an
amazing friend of mine for for many
years I see it I see it online but to
see it in person just makes me so [ __ ]
happy like if you ever watched one of
those movies where like there's like oh
oh wise man like Oracle you know but
like he doesn't always like make himself
available but you can like live through
his teachings and you feel like you know
him I would always listen to everything
he would say and it really sat with me
there was this one thing he said one day
you're gonna die and you should do
something about it and I didn't know
exactly what that meant until I felt
until I felt like I was actually gonna
die I always had this one dream of being
an athlete
and growing up like I love basketball
but I was the chubby kid playing sports
wasn't exactly like the right fit for me
in life it seemed like I was overweight
and I was very insecure about it and
when you're insecure about things
sometimes you mask it and you cover it
up with something you can be good at you
gotta have something that's you and I
was like I'm a CEO Charlie's like Junaid
I'm CEO Charlie and at that early I got
a very what I truly wanted to be and I
did business and I got good at it and as
the business grew you know like I got up
over three hundred and four pounds and
you know with all this amazing things
that were happening in my life I was
never as I'm unhappy I was very
depressed look how bad I look this for
this whole my name is Charlie Jabba Lee
and I've been overweight my whole life
my addiction to food just just beats me
down
i binge eat until i get sick and i do
that so i'll never want to be in jena
again but it's just a downward spiral I
don't want to be in a depression anymore
health health is is the most important
thing to business because you're looking
at a guy who who had all the business
you know he could ever want
but with my health not being in order it
meant nothing
one of my best friends and then it's got
cameras he saw something in me and he's
he knew that I had been dieting my whole
life and he said you know we're gonna
run we're not gonna we're not going to a
diet anymore and we ran three marathons
and you know people don't believe me
when I say this I gained weight I gained
30 pounds through the marathon process
and at it it seems it seems kind of hard
to believe but those one of those
situations where you just keep trying
but you keep messing up at the same
exact time but you're super ambitious
but when you mess up it it just earned
us all the ambition and I felt stuck
I was just askin like what else to do
I'm doing everything and ran three
marathons and gained weight and I
thought I was at rock bottom and then
things got it things not work I knew
something was wrong but I didn't know
what was wrong and one day I woke up and
willing to start this food and this is
when he was doing this davon sands
flutter their whole game yeah like I
wake like we are the top of your
business game and it never a sad never
wake up Amos spinning I'm like oh this
isn't good and then I got out of bed
wait to pick up the shoes pass out
window dr. brain tumor wraparound left
optic nerve coronary artery because
started corroding the top of my spinal
cord
at that point is like when you gave me
like my secret sword to go slay my
dragon
like I'm like imma change everything
this is the Sun nation I've changed
everything it was scary because I knew I
knew something was really really wrong
and I felt like I was about to die and a
brain tumor the brain tumor had grown
and it was wrapped around my left optic
nerve my coronary artery and said it
could start corroding the top of my
spinal cord the levels of like the
hormones and everything that my brain
tumor puts off we're at like like ten
thousand times what they should have
been and
so I went on a journey and that's when
that's one like that that voice of Gary
was kind of in my head like he said like
one day you're gonna die you know you
got to do something about it and and the
social pressures were strong you know
but I knew something drastic had to
change and the social pressures are like
you're supposed to have this much money
your bank account you know you're
supposed to have nice cars they're
supposed to you know do all these things
that relate to business and money but at
this point none of that made made any
made any it didn't matter to me it
didn't matter to me anymore so I just I
just heard a voice I was like go on a
journey I'm left I left my my company I
left in the city of Atlanta I left
everything because I wanted to start a
whole new life where I could do it right
this time and I became the exact
opposite of every single thing I was and
I was this workaholic working 100 hour
work weeks and I just wasn't a happy
person I was depressed and anti-social
and and now you know I've lost 125
pounds training for Ironman in March in
New Zealand and I'm reversing my brain
tumor and a vegan and I live in
California
and I'm chasing my dream and Wow it just
feels amazing to chase to chase my dream
and I know you know my story might be
the opposite of most people's because
most people you don't want to chase
their dream of success but the same
rules
I believe apply that you know if
something's not right and you're stuck
and then you feel like it's if you felt
like how I did like I felt stuck I felt
depressed I felt like there were no
answers and I would just look on social
media and everybody seemed to be so
perfect I want you to know that you know
we're all not perfect we're all going
through something it's just none of us
show our vulnerability and I want to let
you know that if you're stuck that you
know there is somebody like you who felt
stuck and couldn't figure it out and we
look out into the world and see that it
just seemed like everybody had it
figured out but that's the message that
that I want to give because I've seen
both sides of the spectrum of the
business
chasing my dream in the help chasing my
dream and I want you to know that you
know there there is a community of
people who will help you if you jump in
this room pool you can't just put your
your toe in like what you gotta jump and
when you jump you've got to learn really
really really fast or you're gonna die
and when I jumped in I realized that
when I was struggling there were so many
people there to help me like I was
scared to make that big jump but then
once I realized that all these amazing
people jumped in and helped me that
means I could try again
[Music]
[Music]